معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
اخر التطورات ان كان بخصوص الغرات المعارك
وكذلك اعداد الشهداء كيف تبدو في هذا
اليوم اعداد الشهداء ترتفع شيئا فشيئا
ويوما بعد اخر خاصه في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه
اغلب المحافظات في قطاع غزه تعرضت الى قصف
اسرائيلي بدايه من شمال القطاع وحتى رفح
في جنوب القطاع في رفح قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ارضا زراعيه قرب
الحدود المصريه مع قطاع غزه ولكن لم تخلف
هذه الغاره اصابات الغارات ايضا مستمره في
مناطق خانيونس المختلفه في المناطق
الغربيه تتكثف الغارات الاسرائيليه القصف
المدفعي كذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي مستمر في
نهجه في نسف المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه
بتلغيم بالمتفجرات ومن ثم نسفها ب من خلال
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي القصف المدفعي
يتركز في حي المناره في المناطق الغربيه
في حي الكتيبه في منطقه وسط البلد في
خانيونس لكن الاهم في هذه المحاور وهذه
المناطق هي هو مستشفى ناصر وايضا مستشفى
الامل الذي اقتحمه اقتحمته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وما زالت ايضا تقصف المنازل
المحيطه بهذا المستشفى يتواجد في المستشفى
مئات من النازحين الفلسطينيين وايضا
الطاقم الطبي في المستشفى من المعروف ان
المستشفى التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
مستشفى الامل وايضا المركز الذي بجانبه
يحتوي على العش المئات من النازحين
والعشرات من الاطقم الطبيه واطقم الاسعاف
وهو المركز الاساسي والرئيسي للاسعافات
وتوجهها الى نقل المصابين وهذه العمليه
الان متوقفه بسبب استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي واستمرار محاصره هذه
المستشفيات من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي يركز عمليته
العسكريه في خانيونس وبالتالي القصف
المدفعي القصف من الطائرات الحربيه الاكثر
كثافه والاكثر عنفا هو على خانيونس ايضا
الجيش الاسرائيلي مستمر في نصب حاجزه
الاساسي والرئيسي في تلك المنطقه على
المفترق الرئيسي والشارع الاساسي لمدينه
خانيونس الذي يصل ما بين خانيونس ورفح
ويجرد النازحين من امتعتهم من اغراضهم
ويجبرهم على النزوح الى مدينه رفح الى
المجهول بلا ماوى بلا اي اغراض ولا بلا اي
امتعه او فراش في ظل هذا البرد قارس ايضا
الجيش الاسرائيلي مستمر في اعتقال
والتنكيل بالرجال في مدينه خانيونس الذين
يحاولون المرور والنزوح الى مدينه رفح بعد
ان طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي منهم ذلك وبعد ان
قصف عدد من هذه المنازل ايضا مستشفى ناصر
وهو المستشفى الاكبر في خانيونس محيطه
يتعرض الى قصف ما بين فينه واخرى شكرا
جزيلا لك هشام زقوت مراسلنا من
رفح